[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains d'entre vous se souviennent de
leur premier mouvement dans le monde du
travail
moi je m'en souviens bien
j'étais débordante d'énergie plein de
bonne volonté
j'avais plein d'idées
mais je dérangeais beaucoup aussi
typiquement j'étais le genre de personne
qui remettait toujours tout en question
qui n'hésitait pas à dire au management
directement quand j'étais pas d'accord
avec leur décision en réunion j'étais la
personne qui faisait la blague de trop
celle qui met tout le monde mal à l'aise
j'avais du mal à attendre mon tour pour
parler je dérangeais j'étais perçu comme
rebelle
imprévisible
malpolis et j'ai envie de dire mal poli
je rentrais pas vraiment dans les cases
j'étais pallice
maintenant on est treize ans plus tard
j'ai 37 ans et je suis coach
et mes clients ils sont comme moi
ceux des personnes qui ont un tdah
trouble déficit de l'attention avec ou
sans hyperactivité
je suis venu vous parler de ça ce soir
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'il est
temps et qu'il est essentiel de
s'intéresser à ce type de profil bien
particulier
le tdah
c'est une différence neurologiques qu'on
a donné naissance
le cerveau tdh il a une anatomie qui est
bien à lui bien singulière et il a une
irrégularité dans sa production de
noradrénaline et de dopamine ce sont des
neurotransmetteurs qui sont impliqués
dans des processus très pratique dans la
vie de tous les jours comme
l'apprentissage la motivation la mémoire
voilà
et
je vais y arriver j'ai besoin d'un peu
d'encouragement peut-être
on pense souvent que le tdah concerne
principalement les enfants
on parle des enfants hyperactifs mais
ces enfants deviennent des adultes
ça concernerait 2 à 5 % des adultes
selon les études auxquelles on se réfère
parfois plus
et ces adultes passent leur vie à
naviguer un monde qui est pas vraiment
formaté pour eux
et une partie d'entre eux qui va bien
réussir qu il a même très bien réussir
dans ce monde mais à un coût qui est
invisible aux autres mais qui est réel
et qui est conséquent
d'où mon propre diagnostic il y a dix
ans dans le bureau d'un psychiatre à
luxembourg
suite à deux épisodes quasi consécutifs
de dépression et de burnout
parce que je passais mon temps a
surcompensé
jeu masqué jeu camouflet
toutes sortes de déficit de problème
avec notamment le fonctionnement
exécutif alors qu'est ce que je veux
dire quand je parle de fonctionnement
exécutif je parle de gênes processus
très pratique dans la vie de tous les
jours comme je le disais ils sont pas
tous là
mais je vous en ai donné un petit
échantillon
et maintenant je vous laisse imaginer
avoir un cerveau qui a des problèmes
avec ça tous les jours
plusieurs fois par jour
et dans plusieurs domaines de votre vie
alors peut-être que certains d'entre
vous se disent je suis pas dans la merde
c'est pas faux
ses facultés elles nous sont accessibles
mais que dans certaines circonstances
des circonstances bien particulières
dans lesquelles on se fait plaisir dans
lesquels on est passionné donc on va
pouvoir y accéder
seulement si on prend l'exemple donc
d'un collégien qualité des esh qui
n'arrive vraiment pas à se mettre à ces
révisions qui arrive vraiment pas à se
motiver juste lui dire meta4 six mètres
force soit un peu fait un effort c'est
un peu comme si on disait un aveugle tu
veux pas essayer d'ouvrir un petit peu
plus grands les yeux pour voir si ça
t'aide
donc en parlant de problèmes de vie moi
je voulais vous parler un petit peu de
la vision de la vue du temps quand on a
le tdah
quand je faisais mes études de droit à
londres
on avait une personne qui était posté à
l'accueil et qui réceptionnait tous nos
devoirs noter cette personne elle avait
un tampon horodateurs parce qu'on devait
soumettre nos devoirs donc pas seulement
à une date précise mais à une heure
précise après ça ça comptait pas et moi
mes devoirs je les rangs des d'une
manière particulière parce que la
première page était à temps mais pas les
autres c'est possible je vais vous
expliquer j'étais donc dans la
bibliothèque en train de faire les
dernières retouches avait pas dormi de
la nuit a entendu j'avais tout fait à la
dernière minute je commençais
l'impression j'amenais la première page
cette dame qui vous l'aurez compris à
force était devenu ma complice et
pendant qu'elle tamponnais ça moi je
retourne et je courrai quatre à quatre
les escaliers vers la bibliothèque pour
récupérer le reste du document et on
allait l'agrafé ensemble et mon devoir
était remis à l'heure
alors peut-être que certains d'entre eux
vont se dire ok mais les étudiants on a
tous fait ça tous les fruits de tête
d'un mythe oui sauf que moi je savais
pas faire autrement j'étais incapable de
faire autrement et j'ai su plus tard que
c'est parce que quand on est quand on a
un tdah qu'on était dh
on a une myopie du temps
on ne voit que ce qui est maintenant de
l'ordre du maintenant
le maintenant il est dans notre champ de
vision temporel et tout le reste ben
c'est pas maintenant
et donc tout ce qui est à faire dans
l'avenir
deviendra viendra au premier plan de
notre attention que son camp ça sera un
sujet du maintenant pour vous aider un
petit peu à vous figurez ça imaginez une
parfaite ligne de dominos et vous vous
mettez devant le premier vraiment le nez
devant vous voyez pas les autres vous
voyez même pas s'il y en a d'autres vous
savez pas quand le projet arrive vous
pouvez voir ça que si vous bougez faire
à droite à la gauche prenez un petit peu
de hauteur cette prise de perspective là
elle n'est pas accessible à un
diagnostic était d âge
alors c'est pour ça on gère pas bien
notre temps parce qu'on le voit pas
comme les autres
peut-être que vous dites d'accord ok ils
ont pas est super bonne notion du temps
mais oui il y aura une vague idée de ce
qui est important de ce qu'il doit faire
malheureusement encore une fois c'est
pas si simple
parce que la notion d'importance on
l'intègre pas vraiment comme les autres
on la comprend c'est ce que ça veut dire
on a compris mais dire un enfant tdh
qu'il faut écouter la maîtresse parce
que c'est important ou dire à son mari
tdf qu'il faut payer l'amendé avant
qu'elles soient majorées parce que c'est
important oui ils le savent mais
l'intention de le faire va se traduire
en action que si cette chose vient se
mettre au premier plan de leurs
attentions
alors moi je décris souvent ça à mes
clients par l'acronyme unique
l'urgence on a vu
le n pour nouveauté le i pour ce qui est
intéressant est le c pour challenge si
une personne tdh est présenté avec une
tâche qui n'a pas un de ces éléments
c'est mort
c'est d'ailleurs un petit peu sur sa
cage il le méthylphénidate qui est la
molécule la plus fréquemment prescrites
au profil tdh c'est un peu plus connu
sous le nom de ritaline son ancien nom
cette molécule ce qu'elle fait c'est
qu'elle va
agir sound système de récompense elle va
nous faire anticiper une récompense par
rapport à l'effort qu'on fournit qui est
plus grande que ce qu'on verrait sans le
médicament
donc pendant un petit temps elle va nous
rendre
un peu plus normaux un peu moins tdh
alors petit problème avec le nom on n'a
pas un déficit de l'attention en réalité
on a juste une manière différente de la
louer et de la gérer la plupart des gens
ont une attention dit en projecteurs on
fait attention à une chose à la fois en
séquentiel de manière linéaire
pour le cerveau tdh il va aller il va
aller s'emparer de tout ce qui peut
capter son attention sans toujours faire
le tri donc la moindre pensée la moindre
émotion le moindre bruit pour certains
de mes clients la moindre odeur va
devenir en fait un stimulus est une des
nombreuses balles avec les avec lesquels
le cerveau tdh il jongle en permanence
alors ça aurait était canon que
j'apprenne à jongler pour ce soir mais
je me suis pas prêt à temps
mais il ya un revers positif à ça à
cette manière d'aller vers ce qui nous
branche est qui nous passionne c'est
parce que quand on en attrape une balle
comme ça qui va devenir plus
intéressante que les autres on peut
tomber dans un versant dans l' inverse
de cette attention multi focaliser et on
va aller dans un état de concentration
qui est difficilement égalable
d'ailleurs par les personnes qui sont
pas concernés un état des pics de
concentration vraiment intense
parfois on en entend parler dans les
livres de productivité on parle de flou
on parle de 10 points
dans le contexte du tdah on va parler
d'hyper focalisation
c'est un état de
de performance mais qui qui veut dire
que pendant toute la durée
de ce flou
ici on a un spécialiste du flou qui
décrit sa on est dans un état dans
lequel la tâche devient auto telli qu au
tout et licques ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que la tâche se suffit à
elle même on va faire les choses de
manière complètement naturel ça va
couler ça va venir tout seul
quand on est passionné on rentre dans
cet état là
et les motivations temps et fort
ça veut plus rien dire c'est un autre
monde
quand on est dans cette phase là par
exemple votre collègue tdh s'il est
complètement happé par quelque chose et
qu'il est en état d'hyper focalisation
il va pouvoir voir des choses que les
autres n'auront pas forcément vu
il va pouvoir avoir des idées que les
autres n'auront pas forcément une
et autour de ça il ya pas mal de
recherches qui ont été faites plusieurs
chercheurs se sont penchés sur la
question du lien entre la créativité et
le tdah leur conclusion c'est que les
profils tdh ont un potentiel créatif
supérieur à la normale parce qu'ils ont
une tendance naturelle à l'anti
conformisme
à la pensée originale à la pensée
divergente et puis alors mon préféré
aussi c'est apparemment on aurait une
facilité naturelle à a dépassé les
limites de ce qu'on sait c'est à dire
qu'on va pas se laisser influencer
par ce qui existe déjà ou ce qu'on sait
déjà ça s'appelle l'expansion conceptuel
je trouve que c'est plutôt cool
alors peut-être que certains d'entre
vous chefs d'entreprise ou managers se
disent mais c'est génial
pourquoi elle est venue se plaindre
d'avoir un potentiel créatif supérieure
celle là ça devrait bien se passer pour
elle dans l'entreprise boîte c'est pas
si simple en théorie les entreprises m
parler et dire qu'elle est accueille la
créativité parce que ça veut dire
innovation ça veut dire réactivité ça
veut dire nouvelles solutions à des
problèmes
mais la pratique est beaucoup moins
simple en réalité
29 % des managers britannique pendant
interrogés seraient mal à l'aise à
l'idée d'embaucher quelqu'un comme moi
la moitié d'entre eux disent dans cette
ruche dans cette dans cette enquête
disait qu'il serait mal à l'aise à
l'idée d'embaucher une personne neuro
atypique parce qu'il ya pas que les tdah
à en termes de neuro atypie ya aussi les
personnes sur le spectre de l'autisme ou
les les dyslexiques les dix numérique
les fameux profil dit c'était rien à
plein d'autres
la réalité c'est que
notre comportement gêne en entreprise
met mal à l'aise les autres et en plus
de ça
apparemment les gens ont un problème
avec la créativité un problème
inconscient un biais cognitifs
inconscient
on a une étude qui dit que l'isi qui
vient de sortir avec toute fraîche cela
m'intéresse beaucoup
apparemment quand on présente les gens
avec les termes créativité et vomi ils
réagissent de manière similaire
c'est vous dire si on aime les créatifs
en rire
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
le jeune tdf qui arrive sur le monde du
travail déjà il a défié pas mal de
statistiques puisque bas il est pas en
échec scolaire il peut être pas en échec
universitaire il n'est pas en prison
il ya plus de tdah en prison aussi
mais même en ayant défié ses
statistiques il va se retrouver avec
cette double peine des managers mal à
l'aise et puis s'il arrive à apporter
quelque chose par leur différence leur
manière de penser différemment mais bon
se prendre la deuxième couche qui est un
malaise un inconfort par rapport à la
créativité et cette manière justement
d'être différent et ce malaise
j'ai mis des années à pouvoir mettre des
mots dessus et à vraiment comprendre
qu'il était là et je peux vous dire
qu'on le sent
on le sent tous les jours on sent qu'on
dérange
et mes clients à ceux des personnes
d'ailleurs qui soutient souvent des
postes à haute responsabilité
et qui à 40 ans ont tellement camoufler
justement pour réduire cet inconfort qui
se sentent plus eux mêmes
j'en ai plusieurs qui me disent va j'ai
tellement j'ai tellement peur de me
louper que je suis systématiquement en
avance pour tous mes rendez vous
imaginez la perte de temps sur une
journée
sur une vie
alors c'est un petit peu ça que je suis
venu vous raconter aujourd'hui pourquoi
parce que
il faut pas juste du courage pour être
des dh pour avoir le courage de masquer
moi je pense qu'il faut plutôt avoir le
courage de se dire qu'il y avait des
possibilités de s'adapter le tdf ça peut
être un super pouvoir si on a les outils
et les circonstances qui s'y prêtent
mais il faut deux parts de courage d'une
part faut que les personnes aux profils
tdf se disent j'arrête d'essayer plus
fort j'essaye différemment j'assume ma
différence mais pour ça elles ont besoin
de l'espace de la tolérance et de
l'accueil de leurs tdh et de leurs
différences par les autres
les autres
doivent avoir le courage d'assumer leur
part de l'inconfort d'y faire face dit
travailler et peut-être peut-être que
nos enfants n'auront atypique vos
enfants neuro atypique pourront évoluer
dans une société et dans des entreprises
où ils peuvent réussir
non pas mal gré et non pas avec mais
pourquoi pas répond grâce à leur
différence
merci
[Applaudissements]